can we talk about liver King yeah sure I
know now this is like the fifth time
that you're gonna yeah that's how I was
like we had to roast you because like
when
um we had to what we had to roast no
because when Mr Beast came on like he
did like nine different podcasts right
two days leading up to ours right and
then and then I knew you were coming on
because like we scheduled this what like
a month ago or so yeah something like
that and I dm'd and I was like oh you
gotta come on we've been waiting for
this and then and then like you know
whatever it was four days ago or
whatever you were the one that broke the
liver King story and I was like oh this
will be [ __ ] great he's about to come
on our show and then in the three days
leading up you've been on like nine
Pockets now and all talked about the
same thing and I was like God damn it
I've only I've only talked about it with
so Rogan and then Zach who was in the
video and he helped me he did the
charlatan segment yeah I watched a
little bit and then uh his roommate
Chris so I was with them at the same
time and they're both in Austin so it
was just like a natural segue so yeah
yeah so did someone Reach Out to you
with the leaked blood work or whatever
yeah it's actually
um the coach of liver King is uh I guess
he's talked about it now as a friend of
mine yeah so he was the one who did it
yeah well liver King reached up to me
too personally to coach him and then he
also reached out to this other guy I
just never saw the email from him
personally interesting dang do you think
he would have done it had you known well
if in the email there was disclosure
about I'm gonna get you to help me to do
all this [ __ ] yes sir no yeah yeah so
did the coach feel like conflicted about
it is that why he oh yeah that's why he
like exposed him yeah but the a lot of
the inherent issue with it was there was
no disclosure in any of the
communications about hey I'm gonna take
the help you provide to then Aid my
fraudulent Mass scale yeah like
deception essentially yeah so it was
kind of like I don't know kind of [ __ ]
up to put so many position where you're
forcing them to like Aid and a bet your
yeah thing so the wild thing too was one
of his uh I guess somebody in his
company emailed me and he was like video
content idea you know uh can we get on a
Skype call I want to talk about uh Brian
liver King's uh issue with processing
HGH this could be a good YouTube video
and to me that was really weird because
I guess maybe at that time they were
planning on being open about his
hormones because this was still
pre-inception of his brand
and I didn't see that email either but
it's like it makes me wonder if I answer
that email and I made a YouTube video
about it like the guy said I could then
does he not have lied this whole time
like wow yeah wow so I don't know if it
was like a last minute decision he was
on a podcast and then just decided yeah
I'm actually Natty yeah yeah because
once you make the statement you know you
can't I guess you can't go back on it so
I don't know if it was like a last
minute audible he called and he's you
know no one's gonna find out [ __ ] it
I'll just say it I don't know much about
him because I feel like every time I've
seen him I've just like rejected same
like it's just such like a oh I'm a meme
he's such a perfect like formula for
being [ __ ] everywhere yeah because
he's such a character that I'm just like
I just hate that [ __ ] so I just rejected
it does he actually follow the [ __ ] that
he says he does or is it just like he's
a complete fraud where it's like he
doesn't do the nine whatever ancestral
tenants no he follows it like but he is
steroids how much steroids was he on
um well again we don't know for sure
that if what he said in the email was
actually what he was doing or not so a
lot of people interpret the stack is oh
this is so much stuff and it is on the
surface but the gear is actually not
that for a like a massive dude it's not
that insane but there is a decent amount
of stuff that is very much not HRT
consistent like if you're because again
I don't know if you've seen his apology
video I watched a little bit of it I
watched a couple minutes and I knew I
was not going to appreciate anything he
had to say because I was just zoning in
on little details of the way he was
saying things it just had me laughing
like when he comes on the first 30
seconds and he's like
I [ __ ] up and like the way he says it
I just kept rewinding that and I'm like
all right I'm not gonna be serious about
this let me just get out of here and not
even try to form an opinion I'm not
gonna be like she thought it was a bad
apology oh yeah yeah definitely yeah I
thought the beginning was fine it was
just the tangents after into yeah yes I
thought that part was like ah [ __ ] man
like you're doing good like now you're
now you're kind of rewinding a little
bit something else that put me off in
the beginning was what didn't he start
it by saying you know when I made lots
of money before all this yeah yeah he
was like I was rich before that
immediately I was like get the [ __ ] out
of here man was he because I've heard
him say that before I've heard him say
it was definitely he had existing brands
that were established but it was
these are Niche products like these
organ meats that are desiccated
freeze-dried capsules it's not something
at scale that is very like marketable
especially if you don't have a viral
Persona kind of putting it into the
mainstream it's very very much somebody
who knows what they're looking for going
to find it and the brand he had was very
established and was successful but to
portray it in a way that the push of his
brand had such a minimal influence on it
if not if not a negligible amount as He
suggests like you guys know how
nonsensical that is yeah yeah yeah well
that it's insulting almost to people who
understand social media in any capacity
yeah I guess that to me was the first
thing that made it feel like oh this is
going to be so disingenuous like to just
kind of lead with well I was rich before
this yeah like almost to say like
I almost interpreted as like are you
kind of saying like you didn't even need
to be liver King I think it was very
much to portrayed in a way like my
intentions were so Noble and it was not
monetary
incentivized yeah okay so yeah if my
businesses are as successful now as they
were before and I was already rich it's
not me trying to get rich uh it was that
I was already rich yeah so I can see why
it was portrayed in that way I just
don't think it hit because I don't think
anyone believes him how much money do
you think he was making because of his
persona
I don't know man he has a bunch of
different brands some of them I don't
even think are publicly known so it's
tough to say yeah like it's definitely
in the tens of millions probably but
it's gross I don't know what his net is
so it's just kind of speculation and I
mean like how many people will stop
buying his supplements not because of
this I don't know he's gained like 15
000 Subs on YouTube since his apology
I mean he still works [ __ ] hard right
oh for sure yeah he subjects himself to
like intense intense hard work yeah and
to get that physique again it's not like
you could just take that stack and look
anywhere near him yeah like he very much
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] Derek gotta return some
[ __ ] yeah
that's the thing that a lot of people do
unfortunately and I think why a lot of
people like to lie or downplay their
used to is because immediately the
Layman who might
well maybe not even the Layman but just
people who don't understand in any
capacity what this stuff can do or would
do yeah they think that you just inject
[ __ ] become Ronnie Coleman which is not
the case at all yeah you gotta bust your
ass too yeah yeah and eat like a
[ __ ] dude yeah so what are what
are like the amount of gear that he's on
right now if it's true like if you know
what he's saying that's the amount he's
on what are his odds of you know having
a Jammer yeah yeah like when do you
think someone like that like what's the
capability to withstand that much gear
like how how long does it take for that
to really affect you uh it depends
because again like his diets I don't
necessarily think is the most conducive
to avoiding atherosclerosis so he could
end up getting there faster because of
the diet
yeah so you have like so much plaque
buildup that you end up with the Jammer
bro yeah yeah right yeah
Derek you have to remember a word
yeah well one of the reasons the the
coach I know didn't work with him after
was because he asked him to get further
health screening and he didn't want to
do it so oh so we don't actually know
where he's at but in general if you're
in your 40s you're holding that much
size you're on [ __ ] that is not
representative of therapeutic
replacement nothing about it about it is
conducive to longevity and certainly not
ancestrally consistent either yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah like our ancestors were
in the [ __ ] case
nobody was that big
where's the Winstrol yeah dude I think
the Grimace part of it all is like the
fact that
he's trying to kind of Salvage it a
little bit I guess by this weird apology
and stuff
it makes me sad in a way because
could this not have been maybe a wake-up
call and maybe he goes damn I [ __ ] up
and maybe he can I don't know achieve
some longevity maybe that motivates him
to go ah you know what maybe this [ __ ]
wasn't worth it and he just comes out
he's like yeah I'm full of [ __ ] and
maybe he actually goes and gets that
further health screening but the fact
that his reactions to sort of be like oh
no I Did It For Men's Health it's like
damn yeah is this dude gonna [ __ ]
Croak in like five or ten years I mean
it's an addiction right at that point
yeah
especially now that it's out in the open
everyone knows it's very much simply for
vanity purposes and yeah or pushing your
brand in a more viral way because you're
that's bigger than life Persona yeah not
because any of it is like he's not a
competitive bodybuilder he's not trying
to achieve some performance outcomes
that are necessary in sports yeah so
it's like at that point you just like to
be [ __ ] yoked yeah essentially true